Tom Verducci mo beat Network analysts
and look Tom I gotta ask you look this
is a season right now of 2018 is this
pretty much a wide open shot for any
team this year to win the World Series
or are you leaning towards one team in
particular well I'm not leaning towards
one team I'm leaning towards seven okay
Super seven and then we've got everybody
else so essentially we're playing a
little more than 2000 games to find out
who the other three playoff teams are
gonna be among the other 23 but it's
hard for me to think that anyone other
than the top seven teams we're gonna
find a world champion anyway outside of
that top seven so it's Yankees and Red
Sox Indians Astros and then the three do
it division winners in the National
League from last year is Washington
Chicago in LA I think all those teams
are just as strong as they were last
year it's hard for me to see even if
things go wrong for those teams as they
don't make the playoffs you know Tom for
me with my football background when we
get into training camp you're just
trying to make sure your starters don't
get injured you want to make it to
opening day with no injuries but this
you know spring training there were some
significant injuries with some teams we
know Justin Turner with the Dodgers
third baseman he's gonna be out for a
little bit we saw Madison Bumgardner
you know get hit onto his throwing hand
and then recently we just saw a Salvador
Perez he'll be out four to six weeks for
the Kansas City Royals so when you look
at some of these injuries which one you
think has the most is the most impactful
on their team's start or even their
finish Tamia's Bumgarner because you
know listen the Giants had just a
terrible year last year I'm not sure
they could contend this year but without
Bumgarner four it looked looking like
six to eight weeks I don't know if they
can come back from that I mean I am so
much respect for Bumgarner he's just
he's the fulcrum of that staff he means
so much to them that's a tough blow to
come out of the gate without your horse
like that so again it's a team it's a
very good division by the way that might
be the best National League West maybe
the deepest division all baseball and
I'm including San Diego which you know
might not win 81 games but I think
they're improved and they are not an
easy out in the course of a season so it
injury I didn't think the Giants could
afford but you're absolutely right and I
like the football comparison because
that last week of spring training that
everybody first of all they're tired of
spring training it's the long spring
training anyway how many times can you
cover first base on pitchers fielding
drills and also it's like just keep your
fingers crossed you just want to put
them in bubble wrap keep everybody
healthy for that it was last 3-4 days or
last week of spring training and the
timing of those injuries is really tough
shouldn't Rickey's be Kerry and Salvador
Perez luggage by the way man apparently
he's carried two bags on the stairs
but that cell I will say that he's one
of the most humble hard-working people
he probably volunteered to take his own
luggage and somebody offered to take it
for him but it's a shame there's very
few guys in baseball anybody who loves
the game of baseball more than Sal Perez
I mean it's hard to get him out of the
lineup and it turns out his luggage got
out of the lineup it's certainly not his
will to take any days off MLB Network
analyst Tom Verducci joining us here at
the Rich Eisen show Kirk Morrison in for
Rich you can watch Tom coming up on MLB
network's MLB tonight at 1:00 p.m.
Eastern plus Tom will be part of MLB
network's telecast of the Yankees Blue
Jays tomorrow at 7:00 p.m. Eastern Time
Tom we everyone's been talking to our up
in arms about the Yankees and this
lineup you know obviously Stanton along
with Judge all the hitters but no one's
talking about their pitching and we know
you're gonna need some pitching down the
stretch what does their rotation look
like and could that be the downfall to
the Yankees this year you know I think
the rotation is okay and that's all it
needs to be because their bullpen is
just lights-out I don't know that
there's another bullpen in baseball that
has more firepower more swing and miss
stuff more options then the Yankees have
so they don't need say like at Nationals
rotation that's got to take the ball
deep almost every night I think the
Yankees are fine with five six inning
starts just manage the game and that's
what's the bath in Tanaka can do seven
Reno to me is the real deal I mean he
was pushed last year in terms of his
workload that's the one thing I think I
would keep my eye on to see if there's
any fatigue left over from last year
after pitching that seventh month into
the ALCS but
stuff wise man he is he's one of the top
young starters in baseball you got Sonny
gray sitting there and probably the
number three hole for them so he's an
all-star pitcher so I actually think the
Yankees starting rotation is fine it's
hard for me to find fault faults with
that team I mean if you want a really
nitpick you could say that their offense
as powerful as it is has a lot of
strikeouts in it and I think there are
some nights it gets really good pitchers
where they can get shut down because you
know let's face it their game is about
hitting the ball at the ballpark and
they'll do that a ton don't get me wrong
but maybe in a postseason environment
it's their strikeouts that may come back
and bite them I still kind of sticking
with the Yankees theme here in about 15
minutes we got first pitch over in Miami
the Chicago Cubs taking on the Miami
Marlins but it's the Derek Jeter era as
CEO of the Miami Marlins starting how do
you see this season or what is the plan
for the Miami Marlins this year and kind
of going forward is it something that we
saw with the Astros years before because
we saw the wholesale pretty much changes
this offseason how do you see the Miami
Marlins playing out this year yeah I
think it's very similar to what the
Astros did I
I spent a bunch of time with Derek in
the offseason to get a kind of inside
look at what their plan is and you know
he was very forthright you know listen
this team has been not in the playoffs
for a long time at eight losing seasons
they've been last or next to last in
attendance or a decade this team this
franchise needed a lot more than just a
patch job and I think they're doing the
right thing because the worst thing
worst place you want to be in today's
game is the middle of the road where
you're neither a World Series contender
or a rebuilding team and I think they're
doing the right thing now I will say a
lot of what happens with the Marlins to
me has more to do with Gary Denbo that
it does Derek Jeter Dembo is the player
evaluation guru he's the one who really
helped build that Yankee system with
impact hitters people like Aaron Judge
and Gary Sanchez and if he can bring
that same magic to the Marlins you know
and he has made some deals where they've
identified really young players not
major league ready players but really
young prospects so I think you're
looking at a three to five year
rebuilding plan here because they have
gone younger their farm system when
Derek took over was real
really week so it's not as if they have
the Cubs had some pretty good players
already in their farm system I think
they trail the rebuilding plans of the
Astros and the Cubs but they're on that
track it'll take a little while though
MLB Network analyst Tom Verducci joined
the Rich Eisen show and look we're here
in Los Angeles so Todd you got to
understand there's been some anxious
moments here in Los Angeles because I
think people feel like the Dodgers
window is closing
and you don't know what's gonna happen
with Clayton Kershaw at the end of the
year where is that Dodgers window right
now and I know Kershaw was a loyal guy
but did you see him at all possibly
opting out at the end of the year yeah I
think that's fascinating the Kershaw
scenario B I know there's a lot of
attention and rightly saw guys like
Bryce Harper and Manny Machado where
they might wind up it's looking like
those teams and we'll have difficulty
reciting them Kershaw is a little bit
different as you mentioned with the
option there he's coming off two seasons
where the back was an issue let's see
how that plays out and you know I don't
think there's any doubt he's going to
opt out over the three years left on his
contract I do think he's one of those
iconic players though it's hard for me
to even imagine him in a different
uniform right I mean he's like he's the
Sandy Koufax of our generation and I
think to me I look at dodging not so
much as a window but a window that may
change in terms of players that are
involved because their resources are so
good their farm system is so good to me
they'll be like the Braves in the 90s or
the Yankees where you know the the cast
may change a little bit but it's
difficult for me to believe with their
resources that Dodgers will have periods
where they'll go through rebuilding I
just don't see that happening with that
team Tom I hate to do it to you but I
have to ask you you're way too early
MLB 2018 predictions I won't hold you to
a World Series winner but I do want to
know who do you will take it I who will
you take in the AL and the National a
who you think your pennant winners are
going to be at the end of the year well
I'm glad you won't hold me to it as I
said you got seven teams right they're
all capable of the World Series my
inclination right now as we see here
today is Chicago Cubs in the National
League I just like the vibe in spring
I think Kyle schwarber is gonna have a
big year and they almost nothing from
him last year I know he hit some home
runs but it was a down year for him he
looks great
yes he's lost a lot of weight and I love
the signing a Yu Darvish so to me I like
the Cubs a lot in the American League I
will say this I think the Houston Astros
are to me the best team on paper I was
so impressed by their spring training
camp I'm going to pick the Yankees as my
World Series team only because for some
reason it's so darn difficult to repeat
I mean the last team to do it was the
Yankees back in 2000 this is the longest
period in World Series history without a
repeat champion and maybe the Astros are
going to prove me wrong because I can't
think of a reason other than that that
they shouldn't get back to the World
Series they are that good they might be
better than they were last year yeah
we'll see we will see Tom I know I'm
excited and thankful for the time that
you carve god I know you got a busy next
couple of days so we appreciate the time
my pleasure thanks for having me enjoy
the season thanks Tom the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience